hello everybody um I wanted to um do
another interview with um a very
brilliant polyglot we tried to um do
this uh some time ago but we had a few
technical problems so we said said we
had to abort the mission but here we go
again I am with uh Richard simut for all
those uh who have already seen him on uh
on YouTube he's a wonderful poly cloud
and he made a video very famous video
where he speaks 16 languages and for
those who don't for and for those who
already know Richard well you already
know one so it's pretty famous in the
field of languages so hi Richard how you
doing hi Luka I'm doing well thank you
how are you I'm doing fine the weather's
great here and uh so I cannot really
complain um okay let's start with a very
uh uh common question for uh that I
always ask polyal can you briefly talk a
little bit about your life and your
linguistic background yeah sure uh um
well thank you for the lovely
introduction I um hope I live up to some
of the words that you you said about me
um well I was born and raised really in
the United king and my first language is
English and then I had French from a
very early age in fact I don't really
remember ever not being able to speak it
um and then later on we had Welsh spoken
R cuz I grew up on the border area of
England whale
and part of my
family from the Welsh side and in fact
my grandmother's parents learned English
as a foreign language although it didn't
stay as a first language in my family I
did learn it and uh picked it up and
heard it a lot growing
up then I also had um some exposure to
TI as a child too because my father
remarried and when I had family in
Thailand as a young boy and used to use
bits and Bs of time it was never really
really fluent but um it was certainly
enough to kind of when I went there I
could I could make some polite chitchat
with people and yeah sadly a language
that I never ever used and haven't
really used since um I left home to
university
MH
for
[Music]
fr
m
okay
um
for
it
um um yes of doch uh
um
ACC
yeah of
English
for
[Music]
po
fore
spee
for
[Applause]
m
for
what is to
opinion
for
fore
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
um
for
Fran inesco
[Music]
spe
I
see
for
okay
father
yeah
and and
SP in and yeah and it's
yeah
is
[Music]
um
yeah
to five
okay
for
[Music]
fore
for
um okay back to England for the final
question um so what are your future
projects in terms of uh in terms of
languages I know that you're learning
Turkish right now so question is how is
it going with Turkish and um do you uh
do you have any plan on learning um what
is your next language going to
be if I can ask you
that if you have already something in
mind oh that's that's a that's a tough
question
okay yeah well my
priority now
really it is a tough question um my f my
first priority definitely to to continue
Turkish I really want to to take it to
quite a good level because I can use it
where I live and it's it's almost like
um I use this ter kind of a free
maintenance language because I don't
have to make much of an effort to
maintain it on Le it so it makes sense
for me to speak to so I'll finish two P
which should end I should end
in April I guess uh March April I'll do
the exam then carry Straight on with B1
and then I'll have the summer off and
I'll then concentrate again on my polish
at the moment I'm just kind of maintain
my polish at a kind of A2 B1 level and
then I'll I'll take polish triply over
the summer to kind of a B2 maybe C1 if
I'm very very lucky and I managed to to
get a lot of study in and lot of
practice done and then I'll come back to
Macedonia and carry on with Turkish and
do the B2 possibly C1 and C2 as well
next year and that will take me to June
20 the 2013 yeah
and
um and then apart from that well I'll
carry on with my Hebrew keep it taking
over possibly keep carrying on Chinese
but um it's a back burner language for
me now really uh I don't have anyone to
use it with and it's it's not a priority
unfortunately um and then the other
things that I want to do is I want to
refresh my Icelandic because I do hope
to go over to ice and for the aspirent
confence
uh which should be there in a year a
year and a half or so okay well Richard
that well Richard what can I say thank
you very much for This brilliant
interview you're welcome thank you for
um interviewing me for having me along
and always a pleasure to speak to you
always a pleasure for me too bye
everybody